speaking of controversial scientific
claims
we're getting a really controversial
claim from the nfl
as it tries to stave off lawsuits from
people who have been
injured playing in the league so
get a load of this one this is really
quite politically incorrect
the nfl which has gone very very woke in
recent years
which has in many ways led the country
in disrespecting the american flag
in the protest of the star-spangled
banner because of
white supremacy and how they stand for
black lives matter
so the nfl is reportedly trying to stave
off
a one billion dollar brain injury
settlement fund
and claims made on that fund by arguing
that
blacks are stupider than whites that is
one of the arguments that is being made
so this accusation right now is being
made by former redskins ooh
oops am i allowed to say that term i
know that what are they called now
they're called the washington football
team
this is the most vague bland name ever
i'm going to stick with redskins i think
the former redskins running back ken
jenkins
just delivered 50 000 petitions to the
billion dollar
funds administrator uh senior u.s
district judge anita
brody and uh jenkins is is
highlighting something here which is
that you've got to prove that you've had
cognitive impairment in order to be
entitled
for some of this settlement fund or
entitled to it rather
and so you got to show that your your
brain has dropped below the average
performance here what would be expected
but there's a two-tiered system
apparently in in here
because what the nfl is allegedly
arguing
is that black people ordinarily have
lower cognitive
skills than white people so they're so
on the one hand the nfl is arguing
we're black lives matter we're so
supportive
yeah let's protest the flag down with
white supremacy and then out of the
other side of their mouth they're saying
but actually you know blacks are dumber
than whites
now they're saying those both at the
same do you see the conflicting message
do you see why this tarnishes the
credibility
of not just the credibility of public
health people but credibility of
allegedly woke institutions like
the nfl really ugly stuff really bad pr
for them
obviously i haven't seen every detail of
every legal document here but
this is the claim being made by by ken
jenkins and one suspects that the nfl is
going to want to tamp down this
publicity so let's see
let's see if they can answer for it if
you do not ring that bell
you will pay the price i don't want to
sound too much like joe biden here but
you will the price you will pay is
you will not get notifications of our
new videos frankly you might not get the
notifications anyway
based on how youtube reacts to us a lot
of the time
but to give yourself the best shot ring
the bell like subscribe
we'll see you next time
you